All right, let's see if we can solve this problem. We're looking for our four clique.
Now, four clique is going to have to have the property that each of the nodes is connected
to each of the other nodes, so the alt degree or the degree of the node has to be at least 3.
So that actually means we can eliminate some of these edges from the graph. All right.
So the nodes from this graph. Two can't be part of our four clique because two only has a degree of 2.
So let's get rid of that guy. All right. We can device same argument.
We can get rid of 6 because it only has a degree of 2. All right.
Now, everybody that's left has degree at least 3. Let's take a look at node 4.
So node 4 has the property that it has exactly line of degree of 3.
So if four is part of the clique, then it's neighbors have to be the rest of the clique, 1, 3 and 8,
but you noticed that 1 and 8 are not connected to each so 4 can't be part of our four clique.
All right, now that we've taken those edges away, we can see 8 has now a degree of 2.
So 8 can't be part of the four clique, so the only possibility left is that these four nodes
make up a four clique and that would mean 1 needs to be connected to 3, 5 and 7,
3 needs to be connected to 5 and 7, and 5 needs to be connected to 7, which it is.
So if we add these node numbers together, 7+3+5+1 is 16.